you know marlins is the he says the mo i  mean he is the king of random [ __ ] oh  yeah i just there's only one of no  there's only one harlem williams i mean  he's like sir have you ever uh made love  to a dairy queen uh blizzard on a hot  saturday night  uh no well you're not living or you will  yeah yeah he just says these random  things man ma'am if you could look away  i'm doing a show please  yeah sorry i don't like your [ __ ]  eyes can you go to sleep i like your  eyes did he ever say that oh yeah i  don't like your eyes  for about a year and a half and i just  saw him just do some like  phenomenal [ __ ] man that was like  next level and it just made me go oh i  gotta i want to do that i want to get  good he was just like you got to listen  you got to trust to build a moment  gather some info